[Music]
all right good afternoon everyone
welcome to our talk on cloud tasks
point-to-point asynchronous tasks across
micro-services my name is Vinod I'm a
product manager at Google and I'm
co-presenting this talk with Brad and
basing wit from who's a chief architect
at vendor stir and bar teaser who's an
engineering manager at Google a quick
housekeeping note all of you have been
attending the conference and we have a
Dory for question and answers so as the
talk goes along please feel free to add
your questions on the Dory and you know
we'll answer it and then they'll talk so
let's get started so here's a brief
agenda on the talk we're going to give
you a brief overview on the journey of
building applications from monoliths to
micro services and then in that journey
why there's a need for building a task
queue in the process and then eventually
we're going to talk about vendetta's
journey with Google Cloud tasks and then
talk about the salient features of the
product and then probably a quick demo
and then wrap up with Q&A so the first
phase of the journey from of building
applications from monoliths to micro
services consider building a simple
image rendering ml application where you
have a web app running a couple of
modules such as a rendering module and a
retrieval module and a user comes in and
say uploads an image say for example a
cat image and then you know like you run
run some rendering work process that
image a detect that it's a cat
you know frame it and store it in the
back end and then retrieve the image and
then you know see hey I'm a cat it's
detected and so on if you build it on a
traditional web server with a bunch of
modules we have what you call a
monolithic application while building
these applications we may end up with
certain problems and the challenges with
such an application or limitations and
such an approach is that we may have
scalability issues it's difficult to
scale independent components such as the
rendering module or there
Travel module independently it's too
hard it's hard to scale these modules on
independent dimensions such as for
example just CPU memory further you have
slower developer velocity what it may
feature is that you can't do continuous
deployment you have to redeploy your
entire application furthermore you have
a large monolithic code base which is
difficult to maintain and it prevents
teams from working independently
additionally you're also committing
yourself to a long term technology stack
now if you were to rewrite the same
application using micro services where
you have the same image rendering
application but you had to independent
services rendering service and a
retrieval service and the user comes in
uploads the cat image it goes back it's
rendered stored in the backend and
retrieved now each service operates
independently and there are certain
benefits of building an application in
this fashion
the first is that you have better
scalability you can isolate hard
services and scale them independently
services can be scaled on independent
dimensions such as CPU and memory
further your faster developer velocity
you know it supports continuous
deployment the code base can be
organized by each independent service
thereby allowing your to isolate for you
know these services for testing and
deployment and additionally it enables
your teams to work independently and be
more productive lastly it you know has a
shorter term commitment to the same
technology stack so building an
application in such a microservices
architecture you may have certain
additional needs one of the key needs is
having a task queue so so why do you
need a task queue for example if you go
back to the same image rendering
application and suppose you're rendering
service for surrendering hundred images
and say in like in a single loop imagine
if there's a failure even one of the
images then you're you know you you have
chances of failure your application
could break
and so on this could lead to higher user
latency further you have lesser
guarantees of making sure your images
get actually rendered and you know a
single point of failure can break your
entire application now if you were to
just change this and you know fork off
the rendering tasks to a queue and you
know make the queue process the work for
you to minimize user latency and you
know isolate failures of say a single
image and also give you a guarantee of
you know at least once execution your
making sure that your application you
know gives the right level of service to
your users with the right level of
reliability guarantees think of this as
like just the way you would [ __ ] off
threads while writing your application
in any programming language and now
you're just doing that as threads for
micro services so that is the motivation
for having a task queue when you're
wired up micro-services so now if you
take this a step further and you had
many services like a user authentication
service along with the rendering service
and image upload service each of these
services could upload independent tasks
or asynchronous tasks to your cube one
of them can say hey at the end when
their users logging in for the first
time you know kick off certain deferred
emails that can be sent a month later
for registration purposes you could have
your image rendering tasks submitted as
well to the same task queue and each of
these services can then consume the end
results of these tasks accordingly by
doing this this task you lets these
services interact in a more you know
different way and thereby let you wire
up these applications for greater
scalability as we talked of before
so given this context I would like to
now invite BOTS whose customer trying to
build an image enduring application and
he wants to check if Google can help him
in building using a task queue in the
process
developer breaking my monolithic
application the micro services does
Google of anything that helps me
minimize the end-user latency yes we do
can I fork off tasks to be done in the
background yes so it's essentially like
threads from a micro-services exactly I
can do this
programmatically yes does it support
Java yes hang on
yes go yes node yes it sounds really
cool yeah yeah and we have a product and
it's called cloud tasks it's generally
available today please check it out you
know like the product page is amazing it
has all I use cases listed furthermore
to talk about cloud to us I would like
to invite Brad in on stage from vendetta
and his journey on cloud to us thank you
for not excited to be here alright I'm
brain fascinated I'm the chief architect
and desta and I wanted to just give you
a kind of brief overview of our
experiences with cloud tasks to have
over the years of our company and so I
also want to talk about how we also did
uniform task scheduling with bigquery as
well as cloud tasks so just kind of give
you a brief introduction to event asta
we're in Saskatoon Saskatchewan up in
Canada and we build a white label
platform for companies to sell digital
solutions for local businesses so for
the purposes of this demo you can just
really think of you know we build
products for local businesses whether
that's restaurants or doctors or you
know maybe car dealerships you know just
a local business and so you know we've
been around for 10 years now and kind of
when we started as a company it was
really about the time that App Engine
was released by Google and so ever since
then we've been happening customer but
but even just more just as a GGP
customer and you know we've really
utilized all the products you know when
we we probably used them all maybe
except for genomics and in kind of the
last couple years we've been migrating
from kind of this App Engine Python
cloud datastore and we probably have 15
of these projects and we're now decided
to you know embrace kubernetes engine
golang and
Klotz banner and so kind of over the
last two years we've deployed and
shipped 75 of these services and so
something's really core to the identity
of our of our company is that we really
rely on Google to offer us managed
solutions whether that's for databases
or if it's for infrastructure everything
you know we don't have our own servers
we've never had our own servers we've
always relied on the cloud for our
business and so in cloud tasks has been
an important part of App Engine and you
know just until recently we didn't have
no this ability to use cloud tasks until
just as Vinod was releasing an alpha for
being able to push to not average and
targets which is very exciting for us
it's been a missing tool kit for us and
so kind of the history with our task
queues is you know being on App Engine
if you're not familiar with is that
everything always gets put in through as
an HTTP request you know you can't spin
off background requests or background
work everything is always coming on a
DHCP request and for these requests you
have a 10-minute limit and so when
you're thinking of all the work that you
might need to do for you know maybe your
general billing reports or of any of
these complex workflows you have to
think about how you can divide that work
and actually finish it within a
10-minute window and so it really forces
people to think about you know
separating these pieces out and running
them with cloud tasks and so this is
really no different than running
applications on kubernetes engine you
know for us we're shipping you know coat
these services you know dozens of times
a day across many of them you know
countless of them and so as pods are
spinning up and down if you have long
live work you know that just doesn't
really work and so you have to have a
weight that you know check in your
states or gracefully handle restarts and
you know as pods are spinning up and
down there's just countless ways that
you know pods can come up and down and
and so and for us we've really always
leveraged frameworks in order to do this
the very first one that we rose phantasm
and it's a way to run
state machines on Python and App Engine
with cloud tasks and then Google
released the framework called pipelines
which is also for Python App Engine but
instead of it being a finite state
machine it it's more dag based maybe
like Apache airflow but also with
components for doing that produce kind
of applications and then just recently
we've we've begun work on a new
framework for running golang kind of
kubernetes cloud task frameworks and
we're gonna be opening source that very
shortly as well some things that we've
learned over the years is that task
queue is a at least what magic for
execution and so you know we might see
over like a billion tasks that you might
have maybe a couple of duplicates that
happened and so you know when these
things happen you have to make sure that
your application is idempotent otherwise
you're going to have very strange bugs
and you know it'll be very very hard for
you to track those down and so you know
typically these things you know you're
very cognitive when you're writing up
these applications and it's more you
know over time as things are changing in
the codebase and people are changing and
adding that these things become not
items bones so it's very important to
just always remember that and then task
naming is another component that we've
really leveraged for cloud tasks is that
you know you can give each task a name
and that allows you to prevent
duplicates from being emitted but it
also just allows for observability into
your application maybe when tasks are
failing and there retrying it's really
nice to be able to just see that there's
a maybe a customer identifier or just
additional metadata in that name so that
you can just work quickly figure out
what's actually going on oh sorry wrong
way so we have a product it's called
reputation management and so for a local
business maybe I'm a restaurant
we have customers there leaving us
reviews across various sources you know
and maybe it's through social media or
blog posts or you know maybe just
someone would leave a review on a
website and so we go and collect this
data and
presented to an end-user and so we have
millions of SM bees in our system and we
have thousand of these downstream
sources and this turns into a lot of
work that we have to do every day and so
some of these problems that we have may
be API limits and we have different
integrations with different partners and
we need to make sure that you know we're
staying under these limits but also we
just want to be you know a good citizen
and not unintentionally DDoS you know us
being on App Engine and kubernetes
engine it's very easily for us to scale
up to hundreds and thousands of
instances and nodes not all these
downstream sites can handle that amount
of traffic and so we end up trying to
put things into their own queues big it
just becomes very challenging and having
so many queues and trying to manage them
all and so we ended up building a system
called a scheduler and really what it
does is it allows the developer to go
and write a query in bigquery and all of
the emitting rows that come out of that
query end up getting scheduled into
cloud tasks and so one of the features
that cloud tasks offers is that you can
put an execution time of one you want
that task to run and so what this allows
us to do is run this query and put in
you know a bunch of different heuristics
on maybe how you want to schedule them
and so when we're looking and segmenting
by maybe the source information we can
perfectly schedule and uniformly across
this highly dimensional data across the
entire day and so you know we'll end up
having a table that looks like this
where we have this is a table in
bigquery where we didn't you know where
you have business three businesses and
then they all want to go to the same
source to get maybe their reviews and so
this is kind of maybe a very simplified
version of that query but really what
all it's doing is we're using bigquery
when doing functions and we can
partition by the source and we can do a
bunch of date math to smear all of the
work that we need to do across the
entire day and so this turns out to be a
very uniform amount of work that we can
schedule and so you can see here now
that at the end the day we have a
scheduled time and then we can omit that
into a task and then those can't run in
the future and so it worked out
extremely well for us and so this is a
graph here in stackdriver that
what are the heuristics that we've added
here is that instead of starting all
over the work that at the beginning of
the day we've I guess scattered it so
that we slowly started elf the amount of
work so instead of you know going from 0
to 100 really really fast you know we'll
admit maybe 20% of it to start and then
we'll another 20% to start 5 minutes
later and so this allows us our systems
you know if they're cold they can more
naturally scale up and so just in
summary you know Klaas has been pretty
much vital for for us and being able to
build application on App Engine and
kubernetes and you know with our
scheduling system there's a bunch of
different categories and heuristics that
we can do you know we can very optimize
our API usage we can do things like
adjusting for our cost and our speed and
we can even group certain paths together
that might have a caste locality and
that you know you're just adding an
order by onto a column we can force
certain things to run to next to each
other and so with that I'm going to hand
it back to the nod thank you Thank You
Brendan for the product ovie of your
architecture and your use cases moving
on I would like to know do it more deep
dive of trout sauce and its key salient
features specifically I'm going to talk
about trout as being a point-to-point
queuing system for asynchronous tasks
across micro-services to be more
specific what it provides you is
reliable tasks offloading you can
dispatch your long running tasks it's
fully managed completely service and pay
for what you use
furthermore it provides your important
rate limit and retry controls this is
very important in queuing systems when
you have multiple services you know one
after the other and tasks need to be
dispatched through those services these
rates can be configured and you know
customized
based on your needs for your system I'll
elaborate more on that as we go through
this talk furthermore it provides you
for flexible routing with HTTP and HTTPS
as well as with authentication so you
can reach any endpoint within Google
cloud as well as your on 10
systems so going back to our image
rendering application you can now focus
your image running tasks to cloud tasks
in Google cloud and you can do it
reliably fully managed and pay for what
you use
and you can access cloud tasks using
various client libraries across a broad
range of programming languages you can
also use a REST API further you could
configure and monitor the queues using
an intuitive CLI commands and we have a
really good monitoring dashboard that
helps you track the progress of your
tasks in your queue and take corrective
action whenever necessary
so now diamon deeper into some of the
features of the product itself scheduled
tasks delivery is an important feature
that cloud TAS provides imagine your
company that has a subscription service
and a user signs up at the start of the
month for a free trial period and at the
end of 30 days you would like to
probably send out reminder email
encouraging the user to move from you
know of the fleet here to the paint here
then you know when the user signs up you
can schedule those tasks you know thirty
days in advance to be triggered by cloud
tasks and you can trigger a cloud
function to send that email out I know
at the end of 30 days and you know
remind the user to maybe try out the
paid version of the product and so on
many of our customers use the product
for this use case on hence I wanted to
highlight it out the next features rate
controls and I'm going to spend a couple
of slides on this as this is important
so like imagine cloud tops or any
queueing system dispatching tasks of
certain rate for example 10 tasks per
second and so on you can do it at that
particular rate or you could set
configurable parameters and then you
know we cut down the rate to maybe a
lower rate and dispatch it at that rate
why is this important for example in
queueing systems assume that you have a
bunch of services tacked one after the
other and each one has a different
processing capacity say for example here
service one as a capacity of 10 tasks
for second and service two as a capacity
of fight husks was a
but if you start dispatching tasks that
say at a much higher rate then the
weakest link in the chain then you're
going to reach a state of a system not
being in equilibrium you're going to see
a lot of failures and then you'll have
to take a lot of corrective actions to
fix that issue by having a killing
system that can you know help you
dispatch to us at the configurable rate
to the most optimal link in the chain
you'll be able to you know set up a
system for equilibrium and you know the
entire flow in the system for example
here is fight as per second for many of
you who work in supply chain systems and
so on this is very common like it's very
much like inventory management making
sure that each hop in the chain has the
right level of inventory and it's
processing the throughput at the right
rate and this is standard queuing system
practice but having a controlling that
rate from the source of the key you know
the entire system is very powerful and
hence I wanted to call it out here
further moving on having good retry
semantics so going back to the email use
case you know like at the end of 30 days
if I were a subscription company I
really want to make sure that email
reaches my users so I want to make sure
I have really powerful retry semantics I
want to retry many times not only that
during failures I want to make sure that
the time gap between the retry is
minimal I also retry for a certain
period of time so I can set really
intuitive parameters in cloud tasks to
make you achieve that goal similarly you
may have certain tasks or long-running
processes that may not be as you know
user latency specific and maybe delay
tolerant for example if you are running
ml model training workloads that you
know a dispatch in the night and then
the model is stored eventually in the
cloud you want those things to run but
you don't want you know you may have
more delay towards so you can set you
know like lesser number of retries maybe
the intervals between the retry so
longer and you may you it retry over a
longer duration and by having
configurable parameters to help you
achieve those goals is something that
cloud toss provides you furthermore and
lastly flexible routing is something
that I've spoken about before
so cloud toss lets you reach multiple
endpoints over HTTP
GDPs as well as it ought an
authentication across different services
in a cloud such as cloud functions if
you have Micro service running on
kubernetes you can reach that further
you can we've launched new service
offerings just cloud on and clutter on
GK in this conference if you have your
service running on that you can reach
there as well as your on-prem systems by
letting you reach this broad range of
services across the cloud an on-prem
cloud does lets you in our NQ tasks from
anywhere and reach these services so
with that I would like to now move on to
a demo demonstrating some of these
features and then we can move to Q&A so
could we move to the demo slides perfect
thank you
so I wanted to give you a brief overview
of the demo architecture before I start
demonstrating key use cases so what I
have here is the same image rendering
application where in step one a user
submits an image these images get in
cured in cloud tasks and then they hit
an image rendering service which is
running on cloud run cloud run is a
service offering which we launched and
cloud next and the reason I picked cloud
run is it each easily scale up and scale
down to zero so if you don't have any
requests coming and it'll scale down to
zero and it's truly service and this
particular image rendering service pulls
up images from cloud storage and step
three sends those sends the data to an
object rendering micro service running
on cloud run and gke and chloral and GK
is the cloud under experience but it's
on gke and the reason I've chosen that
is because I want to do this processing
on a GPU because I want to do it in
seconds and GK lets you know that you
can configure a GPU a node pool and do a
very quick processing that's the benefit
of the cloud and the end result is then
eventually stored in cloud storage so I
wanted to give the audience an overview
of this architecture before I step into
the demo so to start off with I'm going
to start with the base use case so what
I have is a cloud task queue you know
like in the UI dashboard I have 0 tasks
running and then you know it gives you a
brief overview of the different set of
tasks in your queueing system your the
rate of your queue and so on
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
I'm going to basically do this
particular basic task so basically I'm
going to create a task which submits an
image and then you know renders it and
gives you the direction that it's a cat
so the way I'm going to do it is I'm
going to go into the demo directory
start off with my initialization script
and then submit a request using the
Python client library so I have a script
which makes a cloud task invocation it
submits a request to a URL which is on
the cloud run service and it mentions
that I want you to render this
particular image so so I start off with
that so it's you see that a task God
created I go into the UI and I see okay
God created you got completed as well it
was very quick
so I'm going to do it again so
so you see that the it's very quick on a
GPU but what basically did was it
created a task the task card started
running and because it's running on GPU
it's fairly quick and you see that the
task got executed and I want to now take
you to the output folder and here you
have your cat image rendered so it's
like it's it's the rendering is going on
tensorflow on the GPU node pool it says
that it's a cat it's written with 99%
probability so so this is the base use
case where I submitted a tastic queue it
got processed and I see the end result
now I want to now go ahead and we spoke
Brad and talked about scheduled tasks
and you know I the task ran immediately
right now but what if I wanted a run at
a minute later or month later or so on
so I'm going to demonstrate that
particular use case I'm going to use the
same you know the same script but with
the Python client library but I'm just
going to add a parameter which says do
it after 60 seconds so so you submit the
same task you come to the year and you
see that the task is created it was
created four seconds ago
but it's going to be executed 50 seconds
seconds from now and basically it's a
minute later I could have said it's five
minutes later or go all the way up to a
month and in the interest of time I'm
going to just click through and you know
you can actually you know you can all
you don't need to wait you can actually
start running the task immediately if
you want to so I'm just doing that right
now as well so so this is interesting so
we did so so now we talked about we saw
that these stars were getting created
and each one had a task ID this task ID
was basically a number generator ID that
the system generates to uniquely
identify a task but what if you wanted
to have your you know custom task labels
and so on based on your different
workloads so you know we let you do that
we let you name the tasks and I'm going
to do something similar here I'm going
to submit the same job but I'm going to
use you know like I'm gonna give it a
name let's say April 11th - 1 so we
created a task there you go and you see
the task but now you can see that the
task name is actually the name that I
had provided and you know it
you label to us you can do this for like
if you have different divisions each one
has a different task then you can use
different task names for each division
on tasks coming from that particular
division so lastly I ran it now but this
time I'm actually going to delete the
task and take that action because I want
to move on so so the next step that I'm
going to do is in queueing systems you
always have something as what you called
a poison pill message or a poison pill
task so it's a task that's always going
to fail and I know many of you while
debugging have always tried to find the
needle from the haystack and here what
I'm trying to do is I'm going to submit
an invalid image and this image is going
to this task is going to always fail and
I'm going to demonstrate how to us keeps
read trying and you know I'm going to
demonstrate that particular failure use
case so I'm going to do that same thing
but I'm going to submit this particular
invalid image the task got created and I
come to the UI and I see okay already to
cloud to us is retry at several times I
have set a very low retry frequency it's
point 1 min in 0.1 seconds it's going to
keep on trying you know I'm gonna say
run now it's going to fail again so and
this is really useful I know like root
cause analysis is a key thing that
people look for in queueing systems and
cloud does helps you achieve that all
these operations that I've done from the
UI you can do from the CLI as well as a
client library if you have thousands of
tasks it doesn't make sense to the user
UI to do this kind of analysis but but I
just want to demonstrate that the power
of this particular product so moving on
I'm going to again delete this task from
this queue and then I'm gonna go back so
we talked about a lot of the tasks use
cases how to create a task and so on and
we said that we could also do monitoring
and you know monitoring from the CLI so
I'm going to look at the you know look
at the list of queues in my current
system see what their state is what
their max rate is how many parallel
tasks think in the process our given
time what is the number of retry items
that they can do like it's a
configuration but it kind of this
particular summary command helps me
display that I can go deeper into a
particular queue so like if I want to
describe additional details about a
particular queue
I can do a describe on the queue
it gives me additional details on what
are the different rate limits that but
that particular Q gives you
for example the birth sized contour and
dispatches as well as the retry config
and we talked about a broad range of
retry parameters all of them can be
displayed here and all of them can be
configured from the CLI now I'm going to
submit a small batch of tasks a cloud to
us and I can show you how you know the
system fairly quickly processes it and
then I'm going to walk you through some
kind of so I'm going to submit a small
batch that's creating a lot of these
tasks and as we see this we can I want
to see how the queue performs so you can
see that the tasks have started
executing it's fairly smooth it's fairly
quick it's on the backend your cloud run
so that's spinning up more instances and
scaling up as for the needs and because
it's processing it on GPU it's fairly
quick so be invited to go do these micro
services using this particular task
queue and you know because this is step
you know defer task execution when the
tasks are not there those service
instance as well spin as well spin down
so it's completely in the cloud as well
as service and that's pretty useful in
the power of this particular tool so
some of the tasks have failed so you can
see that quickly retrying they bubbled
up you know identifying the root causes
the needle from the haystack so that's
the demonstration these use cases as
well you know I want to move on with the
demo but you can do a bunch of other
operations like in Delhi independent
tasks but I can also delete all the
tasks in the queue at one shot using the
purge come on so that's what I'm going
to do right now to move on with my demo
for the next use case so so these are
some of the things that you can do it's
pretty quick pretty fast and you know it
does a lot of things like retry and rate
limits now the next thing that I'm going
to demonstrate is so so I know that my
cue can dispatch to us at a certain rate
but how do I determine what is the
optimal rate of this entire system and
I'm going to run a small sensitivity
analysis using my cue with the end
micro-service and what I've done is I've
forcefully a disabled auto scaling at
the end
cluster the gke cluster so it won't
scale beyond a certain point I'm going
to try to figure out what the max
throughput of the system is and I'm
going to experiment that
using cloud to us and figure that out so
I kind of find the optimal flow of the
system and set the rate to that
particular value to to start this I'm
going to start step by step I'm gonna
first set the rate to a really low value
and set it to like one task per second
so I'm going to set that and along with
that I'm gonna didn't start firing a
bunch of tasks thousands of tasks to
this particular killing system so these
tasks get you know started getting
created it takes about 30 seconds for
all of them to get created but as you go
I come into the UI and I see one by one
the tasks are getting queued up but the
progress is fairly slow you know like I
you know like I can you can clearly see
it the rates like one per second six are
completed it's fairly slow and you know
I know that I can do better so so how
better can I do so let's do 10x of what
I gave so let's do let's try to set the
value to maybe ten tasks per second and
see if that helps us I need to go to the
demo directory once again okay
all right
it says it takes about a couple of
seconds for the command to get
initialized but in the process so what
my goal is to see set it to a higher
rate and as I said it to a higher rate
let's just wait for a couple of seconds
for this to load as well in the meantime
so so the goal is to set it to a higher
rate and see if that particular higher
rate is optimal for cloud tasks or not
and if not try to see if you can take
corrective action based on that this is
quicker and practice yeah
all right I'm going to set it to a
different cue
all right
it takes about a minute for this to set
up because I've set up some QPS limits
based on the end dispatch rate so
apologize for that delay so yeah there
we go
so we got the rate set and we see that
the higher rate is said here so as this
high rate is said what you need to
understand is okay I was doing one per
second now I've done ten times and then
this ten point per second this rate is
also is good but I want to understand
like is this good enough and we can see
that at the output queue we also see the
outputs getting processed but the cloud
task queue I feel could do better and
one of the things about this particular
feature is that it helps you do the
sensitivity analysis so we have ten
tasks per second and you know we can go
all the way up to 500 and we want to
find the optimal sweet spot so instead
of doing ten per second if I wanted to
do 100 per second I would have to retry
said the same amount to pay a hundred
per second and then see if there are any
errors at that point so so let me just
try to see if I can do that so
so I've said it to 100 per second and
now at 100 per second we still see that
we can you know we're doing reasonably
well we are processing tasks at a
certain rate we don't see big stresses
in the system you know I can go to the
output folder and you know if I do a
quick refresh I see that the output is
getting populated so so so what does
this imply so like it's cloud TAS doing
really well is could I could I how do I
know that if if I can set a higher rate
is that higher rate really much better
can I do like five times this particular
value can I set it define it per second
and so on so the only way to do that is
you experiment with that value and then
you try to see if there are errors and
then you kind of figure out your optimal
sweet spot with that expression
particular experiment so I'm going to
now set the same thing to find it per
second so if you come back here I've
said to find it per second there are a
lot of tasks in the queue and in a lot
of you know the tasks are getting
processed but you can certainly see that
there's been a sudden change you see
some errors popping up you know like you
see some kind of failures the rate at
which it was crossing at 100 versus 500
seems to be different and this is
basically can be illustrated further by
looking at you know a list of the tasks
you can do that through the CLI so I'm
going to do a list of the CLI I'm going
to list all the tasks from the CLI and
then we got to see if there are any
errors so let's just do that
so what I've done is I've just run a
command which lists all the tasks in the
queue at this point and you can see at
this point where we have a lot of errors
all over the place these internal errors
so so I set a much higher rate for the
queue and I figure out ok this is
probably not the right fraid so so
basically now I need to step back and
then set it to a value which is
basically what I thought was an earlier
optimal value and the reason I was able
to replicate this is because you know I
had forcefully set the the end cluster
to not scale further so I had reached
the capacity of that particular system
and then my sensitivity analysis helped
me find out the optimal rate for this
particular queue and that's pretty much
what helped me figure out ok I can do
100 QPS and I should be fine if later on
something comes up where I need to you
know reduce it further increase it
further I can configure it and you know
take corrective action as necessary so
that was the demo could we switch back
to the slides please
okay great so just a quick recap as well
so so when I created the rate-limiting
problem and you know the place where I
had created the disable auto scaling was
the object detection micro service if
you have any other service where you
have such rate limit concerns like if
you're hitting an API or you know where
their API limits also on you probably
need to have some kind of rate limiting
from your source to make sure you don't
reach those API limits for cost-saving
purposes or even like in this case
scalability purposes the corrective
action I took was I reset the rate limit
but you could actually do something else
as well you could double the capacity at
your end service you could double your
GPU node pool you could do vertical
scaling and you know move from a GPU to
a higher GPU and you can then drain all
the tasks from your queue it all depends
on the users needs like if there are two
personas we're using this particular
product one is a user who's in queuing
to us from an application perspective
and a sysadmin persona who's actually
monitoring the queue the sysadmin tech
can take corrective action depending on
what needs to be done he can increase
capacity or he could limit rate
depending on the need of the art so
moving on I wanted to summarize cloud
tasks a point-to-point queuing system
for asynchronous tasks it offers great
features such as rate limits retry
controls dynamic scheduling dynamic HDV
targets across different services in the
cloud as well as on Prem systems and it
provides HTTP with authentication
[Music]